je vous présente un document qui fait
partie des fonds d'archivés privées
conservées aux archives départementales
de la réunion il s'agit d'un journal
intime tenu par un colon du quartier de
sainte suzanne jean baptiste gris noyal
de lys troubles il a tenu ce journal
pendant près de trente ans entre 1811 et
1838 ce journal parvenu aux archives en
1956 se présente sous la forme de 24
caillé regroupent en 1924 page
la mise en page reste identique au fil
des années en haut de la page sont
indiquées l'année en cours et le mois
dans la majorité le jour les thèmes
abordés dans le texte et des indications
météorologiques
on trouve également dans la marge des
petits dessins destinés à la plume qui
illustre le texte par exemple les décès
sont signalés par une tête de mort
surmonté du prénom le journal de lescout
welt et publié en 1990 sous le titre
journal d'un colon de l'île bourbon qui
est jean baptiste de l'escaut bhl c'est
un habitant autrement dit un colon
propriétaires de domaines où d'une
habitation
il était installé dans un premier temps
au grand hazier à sainte suzanne puis au
kangoo il est né à saint denis en 1776
d'un père officier breton et d'une mère
créole
il s'est marié en trois fois et a eu
sept enfants
c'est un homme très actif un gros
travailleur
collomb passionné par la terre qui
cultivent mais également architecte
bricoleur décorateur de théâtre franc
maçon il s'engage aux côtés de franck
créole qui défend un statut démocratique
de lille
le journal de l'est ce couple nous
renseigne
sur la vie quotidienne d'un domaine
agricole dans la première moitié du
xixème siècle
nous y trouvons des informations que ne
peuvent pas nous apporter des archives
administratives de l'est ce couple nous
raconte jour après jour les travaux
d'agriculture de jardinage ou les
travaux de construction d'aménagement de
sa maison où des travaux de construction
d'une sucrerie
il nous parle également de ses esclaves
qu'ils traitent avec humanité il
travaille avec eux et les soigne comme
les membres de sa famille il nous livre
également des réflexions sur la vie
politique
les hommes et nous rapporte des faits
notables da de la vie locale
par exemple une éruption volcanique où
le piton des neiges qui a été recouvert
de neige
en 1822 le journal de l'est ce couple
constitue un témoignage d'une grande
richesse sur la culture les moeurs la
politique l'histoire de la réunion du
19e 6
moi